Alex was seven. He had a Teddy bear named Tony. Tony had been with him forever. Tony was with him back when he had all sorts of surgery and nobody was sure if he was going to pull through. But Alex did pull through. And afterwards, when the nerves of the family were still jangling, Alex continued to carry around Tony for years, sleep with Tony.
亚历克斯当时七岁。他有一个叫托尼的泰迪熊。托尼一直陪伴着他。早在亚历克斯经历各种手术、没人确定他能否挺过来的时候，托尼就一直陪着他。但亚历克斯挺过来了。在那之后，当家人的神经依然紧绷时，亚历克斯坚持抱着托尼很多年，和托尼一起睡觉。
When he was seven, he took Tony with him to Disneyland. And, when the family got back home to San Francisco from Disneyland, Alex's parents unpacked the bags and looked for Tony. And Tony was not there. Alex's dad, Jon, tells the story.
七岁时，他带着托尼去了迪士尼乐园。当一家人从迪士尼回到旧金山的家时，亚历克斯的父母打开行李寻找托尼，但托尼不在里面。亚历克斯的父亲乔恩讲述了这个故事。
So Alex was in the room and we told him it appears that Tony isn't here. And it took him about a minute to really realize that Tony was gone. And, at that point, he said two things. The first thing is he said that he couldn't imagine life without Tony, and the other is he said, "I feel like I've lost my spirit."
当时亚历克斯也在房间里，我们告诉他托尼好像不在这里。他花了一分钟才真正意识到托尼不见了。那时，他说了两件事。第一件事是他说他无法想象没有托尼的生活，另一件事是他说：“我觉得我失去了我的精神支柱。”
At that point, what's a parent to do? You know, what do you do? So they call the hotel, and the hotel says over the phone they have not found this Teddy bear. And so Jon flew down there the next morning. He tried to be a good dad, rented a car, retraced the family's path, made his way to the hotel.
在那时，做父母的能怎么办呢？你知道，你能做什么？所以他们给酒店打了电话，酒店在电话里说他们没有找到这个泰迪熊。于是乔恩第二天早上飞到了那里。他努力做一个好爸爸，租了一辆车，沿着家人走过的路回溯，去了酒店。
After waiting for a few minutes in the lobby, a security guard came and said, "Well, Mr. Holtzman, we have bad news for you. We know what happened to the bear." And they explained that a maid had seen the bear, apparently, in the garbage and that he'd been thrown away.
在大厅等了几分钟后，一位保安过来对我说：“霍尔茨曼先生，我们有个坏消息。我们知道那只熊怎么了。”他们解释说，一位女佣在垃圾堆里看到了那只熊，显然它被扔掉了。
And so my immediate reaction was well, that's great. That's not bad news. That's good news because at least we know where he is. And he said, "Well, no. You've got to see the problem here." And we went around to the back. And there was this huge sealed dumpster with a compacter on the front, literally, the size of a semi trailer and 25, 30 feet long, at least.
我当时的直接反应是：太好了。那不是坏消息。那是好消息，因为至少我们知道它在哪里。他说：“不，你得看看这里的问题。”我们绕到了后面。那里有一个巨大的密封垃圾箱，前面装有压缩机，字面上讲，它有半挂车那么大，至少有25到30英尺长。
They looked at it and there was, literally, no way into this dumpster. Jon started to despair.
他们看了看，发现真的没有办法进入这个垃圾箱。乔恩开始绝望了。
And I started asking, "Well, when is the next garbage pickup?" And they said, "Well, it's a day from now." And I'm thinking what am I going to do? And, just as we were having this discussion, the truck arrives to pick up this giant dumpster a day early. And this was kind of an amazing thing because, if I had gotten there 15 minutes later, or 20 minutes later, the garbage truck would've been gone.
我开始问：“好吧，下一次垃圾清运是什么时候？”他们说：“就在一天后。”我在想我该怎么办？就在我们进行讨论时，卡车提前一天到达，来清运这个巨大的垃圾箱。这真是一件了不起的事情，因为如果我晚到15分钟或20分钟，垃圾车就已经开走了。
A squad of hotel employees was deployed to travel with Jon and the garbage truck to the recycling plant to search for the Teddy bear. And, you know, there are only two possible attitudes that adults would have towards this particular mission. One, they would be into it, or, two, they would think that Jon's a nut. And, incredibly, none of them thought that he was a nut. But why? Because almost all of them were parents. And, at some point or another, almost all of them had been in the same or a similar situation.
一支酒店员工小队被派去随乔恩和垃圾车一起前往回收站寻找泰迪熊。你知道，成年人对这项特殊任务只有两种可能的态度。要么，他们会全身心投入，要么，他们会认为乔恩是个疯子。令人难以置信的是，他们中没有人认为他是个疯子。但为什么呢？因为他们几乎都是父母。在某个时候，他们几乎都经历过相同或类似的情况。
I mean, you couldn't be a parent without having dealt with your kids dealing with loss, you know? And it's so horrible. And, yeah. I mean, I think everybody rallied to exactly that cause.
我的意思是，作为父母，不可能没处理过孩子面对失去的情况，你知道吗？这太可怕了。是的。我想每个人都完全支持这一事业。
It's interesting because I think that a lot of parents get to points, at different points in their child's lives, where they want to intervene, and they feel like they will not allow fate to hurt their child.
这很有趣，因为我认为许多父母在孩子生活的不同阶段都会想要干预，他们觉得他们不会允许命运伤害他们的孩子。
Absolutely.
绝对是这样。
And they will simply do whatever they can to stop fate.
他们会尽其所能去阻止命运。
There's no question. And, you know, if you've ever had a child who almost dies, it means a lot, in a way, to be able to protect your kids from that kind of thing.
毫无疑问。而且，如果你曾经有一个差点死去的孩子，在某种程度上，能够保护你的孩子免受那种事情的伤害意味着很多。
Well, on this Father's Day, we bring you stories of dads trying to protect their kids and kids trying to protect their dads. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
在这个父亲节，我们为您带来关于父亲试图保护孩子以及孩子试图保护父亲的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, the protection racket that is parenthood. Our program today in three acts. Act One, Paddington's Day at the Dump, the story of a man, a small toy bear, and tens of thousands of pounds of soggy garbage. Act Two, A Trip Down Memory Lane. A son takes his father on one, last road trip to jog his dad's failing memory of his own life. Act Three, Age of Enchantment. Writer Lawrence Weschler and his daughter, Sarah, talk about something that he did intending to be kind, intending to protect her from disappointment, that inadvertently broke her heart, and how she saved the day for the two of them. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，为人父母是一场保护者的较量。我们今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，“帕丁顿的垃圾场之旅”，讲述了一个男人、一只玩具小熊和数万磅潮湿垃圾的故事。第二幕，“记忆小径之旅”。儿子带着父亲进行最后一次公路旅行，以唤起父亲对自己生命中那段正在衰退的记忆。第三幕，“魔幻时代”。作家劳伦斯·韦斯勒和他的女儿莎拉谈论了一些他出于好意、为了保护她免受失望而做的事情，这些事无意中伤了她的心，以及她如何为他们俩扭转了局面。请继续收听。
Act One, Paddington's Day at the Dump. So Jon Holtzman and the hotel employees followed the garbage truck that's hauling the dumpster away. In his car, four conscripts. And, at this point, essentially, this story becomes the movie, Saving Private Ryan. And, you know, why don't we have some of the music from the movie just to set the right mood?
第一幕，“帕丁顿的垃圾场之旅”。乔恩·霍尔茨曼和酒店员工跟着运走垃圾箱的垃圾车。他的车里坐着四个征召来的人。在这一点上，本质上，这个故事变成了电影《拯救大兵瑞恩》。既然如此，为什么我们不放一点电影里的音乐来营造合适的氛围呢？
[MUSIC PLAYING - "HYMN TO THE FALLEN" FROM SAVING PRIVATE RYAN]
[音乐播放 - 《拯救大兵瑞恩》中的《献给阵亡者的赞美诗》]
Perfect. Somewhere in Southern California there's a little bear named Tony. And these four recruits are going to get him out to assuage the grief of one American family.
太完美了。在南加州的某个地方有一只叫托尼的小熊。这四个新兵要把它救出来，以抚慰一个美国家庭的悲伤。
OK, so we're in the car and there is this kind of silence. I made a deal with everybody in the car. I offered each of them $100 for the person who found the bear. And we were kind of plotting strategy of, well, OK, when they open this dumpster, how are we going to find the bear? Where is he going to be in the dumpster? How many days of garbage is there? And, you know.
好了，我们在车里，有一种沉默。我和车里的每个人做了一笔交易。我提出给找到熊的人每人100美元。我们正在策划策略，好吧，当他们打开这个垃圾箱时，我们要怎么找到这只熊？它会在垃圾箱的哪个位置？有多少天的垃圾？你知道的。
And so we finally arrive at the recycling plant. And, first of all, the scope of this plant is not at all what I'd imagined. I expected it to be just a garbage dump. But, instead, it's what I imagine to be, essentially, a modern recycling plant. And there were these huge caterpillar trailers and tractors running around the plant. And there were these huge steel floors. And the scope, the scale, of the place was just really awesome.
我们终于到达了回收站。首先，这个工厂的规模完全超出了我的想象。我以为它只是一个垃圾场。但相反，它是我心目中本质上的现代回收工厂。厂里有巨大的卡特彼勒拖车和拖拉机在跑来跑去。还有巨大的钢制地面。那个地方的规模和范围真是太震撼了。
It's like acres is what you're trying--
你试着说的是占地面积大得惊人——
Yeah, it's just huge.
是的，它太大了。
It takes a long, long time to talk their way into the plant. If they enter, all work at the recycling center has to stop. But, incredibly, finally, they're allowed in under one condition.
花了好长好长时间才说服他们让我们进入工厂。如果我们进去，回收中心所有的工作都必须停止。但令人难以置信的是，最后，他们同意我们在一个条件下进入。
We would have 15 minutes to search this pile. But that's all we could have, which put a lot of pressure on us. Although, I'm not sure we understood how much pressure it would put on us until they dumped the garbage out of the trailer.
我们有15分钟的时间搜查这个垃圾堆。但我们只有这些时间，这给了我们很大的压力。虽然，我不确定在他们把垃圾从拖车里倒出来之前，我们是否理解这会给我们带来多大的压力。
So they dumped the garbage out of the trailer. And, even though the trailer was large, I guess I'd kind of underestimated how much garbage can go in a trailer that size. And so they dumped this out on the floor. And, of course, it spread out, so it occupied this really massive space on the floor. And it was full of this brown sludge, and liquid, and just tens of thousands of plastic bags floating, essentially. Not really floating, but oozing in this--
他们把垃圾从拖车里倒了出来。虽然拖车很大，但我猜我还是低估了那个尺寸的拖车能装多少垃圾。他们把垃圾倒在地上。当然，它散开了，所以它占据了地板上一个非常大的空间。里面全是棕色的污泥、液体，基本上到处都是成千上万的塑料袋。并不是真的漂浮，而是在这种……中渗出——
This soggy sort of--
这种潮湿的……
--soggy mess. Exactly. And I took one look at this pile and my heart truly sank because I just thought I don't even know where to begin.
——潮湿的烂摊子。完全正确。我看了一眼这个堆积物，心真的沉了下去，因为我根本不知道从哪里开始。
A number of the people who came with me jumped in and immediately started ripping open bags trying to find the bear. And so, after 30 seconds or so of taking in the enormity of the thing, I just plunged into this pile along with them. And, watching us do it, these garbage men, the folks who were running the recycling plant, at least four or five of them put on their gloves and started doing the same thing with us. So, at this point, there were a group of maybe eight or nine of us pulling apart bags and frantically looking for this bear.
和我一起来的一些人跳进去，立即开始撕开袋子试图寻找那只熊。所以在领会了事情的艰巨性大约30秒后，我也和他们一起跳进了这堆垃圾里。看着我们这样做，那些垃圾工，那些经营回收工厂的人，至少有四五个戴上手套开始和我们做同样的事情。所以，此时此刻，我们大约有八九个人在拼命地拉开袋子，疯狂地寻找这只熊。
Seven or eight minutes into it I just despaired of ever finding the bear. And I couldn't believe it, you know? We'd come this far, you know? And it just seemed that it ought to work out, but I didn't see how it would. It was just too big. And I remember saying to myself, "Tony, if you're here, you're really just going to have to appear on the surface because there's just no way. I mean, the only way this is going to happen is if you make yourself appear." And the next thing I knew I was holding the bear.
七八分钟过去了，我绝望了，觉得永远找不到这只熊了。我简直不敢相信，你知道吗？我们已经走了这么远，你知道吗？这似乎应该会有结果，但我看不出怎么会有。它实在太大了。我记得对自己说：“托尼，如果你在这里，你真的必须出现在表面上，因为实在没别的方法了。我的意思是，唯一能发生这种情况的方法就是你自己现身。”下一秒，我就发现我手里拿着那只熊。
Wait a second. What do you mean? Do you mean you picked up a plastic bag and you shook--
等等。你是说你捡起了一个塑料袋，然后你摇了摇——
I picked up a plastic bag, and there he was. And he was in a plastic bag, so he was completely dry and unscathed.
我捡起了一个塑料袋，它就在里面。它在一个塑料袋里，所以它完全干燥且完好无损。
How do you explain that?
你怎么解释这一点？
Oh, I don't. You know, I'm a rationalist. I'm not religious. I'm not really spiritual in any way. I'm a labor negotiator. I don't explain it. You know, the thing that's strange to me is not just the way I found him, but we had eight or nine people looking, you know? And why was I the one who found him?
哦，我解释不了。你知道，我是个理性主义者。我不信教。我在任何方面都不太讲究精神层面。我是个劳资谈判代表。我不解释它。你知道，对我来说奇怪的不仅是我找到它的方式，还有我们有八九个人在找，你知道吗？为什么偏偏是我找到了它？
Because you were touched by an angel that wanted to save you $100?
因为你被一位想帮你省下100美元的天使触碰了？
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑]
Jon Holtzman is an attorney in San Francisco. The hotel that deployed its forces to get the bear back, I feel like we should give them credit. Let's say their name on the air. It's the Sheraton Anaheim.
乔恩·霍尔茨曼是旧金山的一名律师。那家部署力量找回熊的酒店，我觉得我们应该给予他们赞扬。让我们在广播里说出他们的名字。是安纳海姆喜来登酒店。
But one last note. Here is the thing about being a father, being a parent. Jon gets the bear. His whole squad is giddy, completely giddy, on the drive back to the hotel. And there, he calls his son to give him the news.
但最后还有一个说明。关于作为父亲、作为父母，这就是重点。乔恩拿到了熊。在开车回酒店的路上，他的一整支小队都兴高采烈。在那里，他打电话给儿子告诉他这个消息。
He was really, really happy. But there was also a slightly of-course-ish response to the thing, which is, "Well, good. I'm glad you got the bear."
他真的、真的很高兴。但也有一些理所当然的反应，那就是：“哦，好的。我很高兴你找回了那只熊。”
He doesn't quite understand it for the heroic gesture that it is.
他没有完全理解这是多么英雄的行为。
I think that's true.
我想那是真的。
He's like, oh, yeah. Dad went down and got the bear.
他就像是，哦，是的。爸爸下去把熊拿回来了。
That's completely true.
那是完全正确的。
The theme to Star Wars is not playing in his head as that happens.
当这件事发生时，《星球大战》的主题曲并没有在他脑海中响起。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Act Two, Trip Down Memory Lane. Joel Meyerowitz is a photographer. He grew up in New York City. In the 1970's, his parents moved to Florida. Joel would visit for a few days at a time. As time passed, his father, Hy, developed Alzheimer's.
第二幕，“记忆小径之旅”。乔尔·迈耶罗维茨是一位摄影师。他在纽约市长大。20世纪70年代，他的父母搬到了佛罗里达。乔尔每次会去探望几天。随着时间的推移，他的父亲海伊患上了阿尔茨海默症。
Before he retired, Hy was a salesman for 40 years. He did a few years as a comic in a vaudeville act before that. He was a boxer. He won his weight class in the first Golden Gloves competition. But now that he had Alzheimer's, the doctor said that he should stay inside, avoid a lot of stimulation.
在退休前，海伊做了40年的销售员。在此之前，他还在杂耍表演中做了几年的喜剧演员。他是一名拳击手。他在第一届金手套比赛中赢得了他的体重级别。但现在他得了阿尔茨海默症，医生说他应该待在室内，避免过多的刺激。
His son, Joel, thought, what if we tried, for a brief time, something different? He wanted to have one last adventure with his father, one last road trip before the Alzheimer's made it impossible to have more adventures. Joel also hoped that, maybe, being on the road, visiting places that he'd been, going back to the old neighborhood one more time, might spark some memories that had been gone for his dad, that had been long, long vanished. It was a gift to his dad.
他的儿子乔尔想，如果我们尝试在短时间内做一些不同的事情会怎样？他想在阿尔茨海默症让他无法再进行冒险之前，和父亲进行最后一次冒险，最后一次公路旅行。乔尔还希望，也许在路上，访问他曾经去过的地方，再回到老街区一次，可能会激发他父亲早已消失、早已消逝的记忆。这是给他父亲的一份礼物。
So they got a camera. They went on a three-week trip driving from Fort Lauderdale back to New York City. Joel Meyerowitz's son, Sasha, filmed lots of the trip. You actually hear his voice only a few times in this footage I'm about to play you. When they set out on the trip, Sasha was 27, Joel was 57, Hy was 87.
于是他们拿了一台摄像机。他们进行了为期三周的旅行，从劳德代尔堡开车回纽约市。乔尔·迈耶罗维茨的儿子萨沙拍摄了很多旅行的片段。你实际上只在我要播放的这段录像中几次听到他的声音。当他们踏上旅程时，萨沙27岁，乔尔57岁，海伊87岁。
Do you know what ocean this is?
你知道这是什么大洋吗？
Well, I'll be honest with you, Joel, I don't know remember. Not the Catskills ocean?
嗯，我老实告诉你，乔尔，我不记得了。不是卡茨基尔大洋吧？
Catskills are mountains.
卡茨基尔是山脉。
Yeah.
是的。
This is an ocean.
这是一片大洋。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Which one?
是哪一个？
Well, I don't know.
嗯，我不知道。
Is it the Pacific or the Atlantic?
是太平洋还是大西洋？
I would take it as the Pacific.
我会认为是太平洋。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Wrong.
错了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, wrong.
是的，错了。
So, which one is it then?
那到底是哪一个？
Either the Permissia? or the--
要么是佩密西？还是——
The Permissic. Right.
佩密西。对。
The Permissic?
佩密西？
The Pershimmoth. The Pershimmoth ocean.
波什摩斯。波什摩斯大洋。
I am at the Pershimmoth. What are you asking me so early in the morning a question like that?
我在波什摩斯。一大早你为什么要问我这种问题？
Where were you born?
你出生在哪里？
1092-- 109207-- no. 159059 East--
1092—— 109207—— 不。东159059——
Well, it was East 100th Street, right? Yeah?
嗯，是在东100街，对吧？是吗？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
He taught me all the street smart things. He set up a punching bag for me. And he taught me how to fight, how to take my stance, how to throw a punch, how to put your body behind it. He had me work out on a light bag too. Like this, you know?
他教了我所有街头的生存之道。他为我架了一个沙袋。他教我如何打架，如何站位，如何出拳，如何把身体的力量集中在拳头上。他还让我练习轻沙袋。像这样，你知道吗？
He always felt that, if you got into a scrape in a neighborhood, that you shouldn't run away. His motto was, "Step in and deliver the first blow." And he said, "Take the biggest guy down." And that was his attitude. He wouldn't stop and run away from anything.
他总是觉得，如果你在街区里陷入争斗，你不应该逃跑。他的座右铭是，“冲进去，打出第一拳。”他说，“把块头最大的家伙放倒。”这就是他的态度。他不会停下来逃避任何事情。
On Morrison Avenue, the block we lived on, he was considered the mayor of the block. Any time there was a dispute that had to be settled, they would actually come and ask him, "What do you think, Hy?" Or, if there were strangers coming through the neighborhood and they needed to be told to get out of there, they'd get him.
在莫里森大道，我们住的那条街上，他被认为是该街区的市长。任何时候有争执需要解决，人们真的会来问他，“你觉得呢，海伊？”或者，如果有陌生人穿过街区，需要有人告诉他们离开那里，他们就会找他。
The scenes I remember are that people would gather in front of our window and they'd yell, "Hymie. Hey, Hymie." And he'd come to the window. And he would adjudicate from the window. He would say, "No. No, you shouldn't do that." And, "He should do this. And, "You get that. Let him alone." It was like the judge.
我记得的场景是人们聚集在我们的窗前大喊：“海米。嘿，海米。”他会来到窗前。他会在窗口进行裁决。他说：“不。不，你不应该那样做。”还有，“他应该这样做。”以及，“你拿到那个。让他一个人待着。”他就像那个法官。
Here they come, baby. Yeah, watch him now. Hey, ya.
他们来了，宝贝。是的，看着他现在。嘿，呀。
[BIRD SCREECH]
[鸟鸣]
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
你好。你好。你好。你好。
Hey, Pop.
嘿，老爸。
What?
什么？
Do you know what this reminds me of?
你知道这让我想起什么吗？
No.
不知道。
Does that remind you of Melvin?
这让你想起梅尔文了吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
哦，是的。是的。
That's what I was thinking.
我也是这么想的。
Yeah. You didn't think of the neighbor that time.
是的，你上次没想起那个邻居。
Do you remember Melvin?
你还记得梅尔文吗？
Yeah, sure, I remember him.
是的，当然，我记得他。
What was Melvin?
梅尔文是什么？
It was a little Chinese-- a little bird.
那是一只小中国——一只小鸟。
A parakeet.
长尾小鹦鹉。
Parakeet, right. I didn't think of the--
长尾小鹦鹉，对。我没想起——
Do you remember the things that Melvin said?
你还记得梅尔文说的话吗？
He called to us. He spoke to us, and he also called his name out a lot.
他叫我们。他跟我们说话，他也经常叫自己的名字。
How did he say it? Do you remember?
他是怎么说的？你记得吗？
Hi, I'm Melvin. Hi, Melvin. Isn't it, "Hi Melvin?"
嗨，我是梅尔文。嗨，梅尔文。难道不是，“嗨梅尔文？”
No. He said I'm Melvin, what?
不。他说我是梅尔文，什么？
Melvin Belvin?
梅尔文·贝尔文？
I'm Melvin Meyerowitz.
我是梅尔文·迈耶罗维茨。
Oh, yeah. [LAUGHS]
哦，是的。[笑]
Can you tell me the story of the time he--
你能告诉我他那次的故事吗——
I can't tell you about it. Look at this. I can't tell you about it. And look at this. Another one coming. Hi, boys. Hello. Hello. We know you. We know your grandfather.
我没法告诉你那个。看看这个。我没法告诉你那个。再看看这个。又来了一只。嗨，伙计们。你好。你好。我们认识你。我们认识你爷爷。
Pop, remember how he used to say my name is Melvin Meyerowitz, I'm a Jewish bird?
老爸，还记得他以前是怎么说我的名字是梅尔文·迈耶罗维茨，我是一只犹太鸟吗？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
That comes back to you?
想起来了吗？
I know it. It didn't. But that--
我知道。没想起来。但这——
Good morning, Doctor Goldberg?
早上好，戈德堡医生？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Remember Dr. Goldberg came to visit Mom when she was sick?
记得戈德堡医生在妈妈生病时来看她吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Do you remember the time the bird flew away across the Bronx? He went out the door on Mom's shoulder and he flew away? And we were all so heartbroken that the bird was gone.
你记得那次那只鸟飞过布朗克斯吗？它从妈妈肩膀上飞出门外跑掉了？我们当时都心碎了，因为鸟不见了。
And then some woman called up. Do you remember? She called Mom and she said, "Do you have a bird named Melvin?" My mother said, "Yeah, we have a bird. It was a green and yellow parakeet." And the woman said, "Well, the bird landed on my window and said, 'My name is Melvin Meyerowitz. I'm a Jewish bird.' And I looked you up in the phone book. And I called a Meyerowitz, and they said, 'Oh, no, that's my brother Hy's bird." We went and we got the bird back. Do you remember that?
后来有个女人打电话来。你记得吗？她打电话给妈妈说，“你们有一只叫梅尔文的鸟吗？”我妈妈说，“是的，我们有一只鸟。那是一只绿色和黄色的小鹦鹉。”那个女人说，“好吧，这只鸟落在我的窗台上说，‘我的名字是梅尔文·迈耶罗维茨。我是一只犹太鸟。’我在电话簿里查到了你们。我打给一个迈耶罗维茨，他们说，‘哦，不，那是我的兄弟海伊的鸟。”我们就去把鸟接回来了。你记得吗？
No.
不。
I'm surprised.
我很惊讶。
Come on. You want to go? You want to go-- don't fall. Take it easy.
来吧。你想走吗？你想去——别摔倒。慢慢来。
[BIRD SCREECH]
[鸟鸣]
Take it easy.
慢慢来。
[BIRD SCREECH]
[鸟鸣]
Do you want to go?
你想走吗？
With the onset of memory loss, it's not only his memories that are fading away, but it's the memories that I shared with him that are fading away. So I could no longer say to him, "Hey, Pop. Remember, we did this," and have him say, "Yes, that was fantastic," remember it. So I found myself progressively left alone with my memories.
随着记忆丧失的开始，不仅仅是他的记忆正在消失，我与他分享的记忆也在消失。所以我不能再对他说，“嘿，老爸。记得我们做过这个吗？”然后让他说，“是的，那太棒了，”并记得它。所以我发现自己逐渐独自面对我的记忆。
And then you look at your own memories and you realize, I've got this handful of really insignificant things, and I've made them my world, my world of memory. And it's astonishing how the few things that I recall to share with him are minor notes, you know, the bird or the handful of things that I ask him. So, that was a lesson, for me, about what it is that rises up out of our experience that we hold onto.
然后你看看你自己的记忆，你会意识到，我手里只有这一把非常微不足道的事情，我把它们变成了我的世界，我的记忆世界。令人惊讶的是，我回忆起与他分享的那些事情都是些小插曲，你知道，鸟或者是那些我问他的事情。所以，那对我来说是一堂课，关于我们从经历中升华出来并坚持保留的东西。
Pop?
老爸？
Yes.
是的。
I want to ask you a few questions about the family.
我想问你几个关于家庭的问题。
About our family?
关于我们家庭？
About our family.
关于我们家庭。
Yes.
是的。
You've got three sons.
你有三个儿子。
Yes.
是的。
What are their names?
他们叫什么名字？
Joel, Ricky--
乔尔，里奇——
And who's your youngest son?
你最小的儿子是谁？
The youngest one is-- I think it's David but I don't remember his name any more.
最小的是——我想是戴维，但我记不起他的名字了。
Joel, Rick, and--
乔尔，里克，和——
Joel, Ricky, and-- yeah.
乔尔，里奇，和——是的。
Stevie.
史蒂夫。
Stevie, oh, yeah.
史蒂夫，哦，是的。
Do you know what Rick does to make a living, what his career is?
你知道里克靠什么谋生，他的职业是什么吗？
Well, he tries to do a lot of stuff. If he were following me, he'd be doing it on the crook, but--
嗯，他想做很多事。如果他跟着我，他会靠歪门邪道做，但——
What's he famous for?
他因什么出名？
Ricky?
里奇？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, in the first place, he's my kid. You are also. And because that alone will get you enough fame.
嗯，首先，他是我的孩子。你也是。仅仅这一点就足以让你出名了。
So you don't know what Rick does?
所以你不知道里克做什么？
Ricky? Rick is a half-time, a part-time-- that book, I don't know the trade name.
里奇？里克是个半职，兼职——那本书，我不知道商品名称。
OK, you're getting closer, Pop. Just try. Try to think about what Rick does.
好的，你离答案越来越近了，老爸。试一试。试着想想里克做什么。
Rick? Rick is an artist.
里克？里克是个艺术家。
Right. You got it.
对。你答对了。
Not?
没答对？
You got it. You got it right. And I'm Joel. What do I do?
你答对了。你答对了。我是乔尔。我做什么？
Ah, you're a doll. You're my best number one for--
啊，你是个玩偶。你是我的第一号——
Come on, get serious, Pop. Do you remember what it is I do? What do I do?
别闹了，老爸。你记得我做什么吗？我做什么？
You make money. [LAUGHS] I'll tell you what. I'll give it to you straight off the street.
你赚钱。[笑] 我告诉你。我直接告诉你。
What's my profession?
我的职业是什么？
What's, what?
什么，什么？
What's my profession?
我的职业是什么？
What's your most attachment?
你最执着的是什么？
What's my profession?
我的职业是什么？
Your profession? Now I've got it figured out. I don't know, a crook, or a thief, or whatever. You're known as an artist, serious artist, in the art field.
你的职业？现在我想通了。我不知道，一个骗子，或者小偷，或者其他什么。你在艺术领域被称为艺术家，严肃的艺术家。
OK. What about Stevie? What's Stevie's business?
好的。史蒂夫呢？史蒂夫的业务是什么？
Judy?
朱迪？
Stevie.
史蒂夫。
Stevie? I don't know.
史蒂夫？我不知道。
Does it bother you that you can't remember your kid's names sometimes? And you can't remember what they do?
有时记不住孩子的名字会让你烦恼吗？而且你记不住他们做什么？
Well, I tell you, yeah. I see them. Hello. Goodbye. And that's it. I'm not complaining.
嗯，我告诉你，是的。我看见他们。你好。再见。就这样。我不抱怨。
Is it hard to see him like this? Does it feel painful?
看到他这样很难受吗？感觉痛苦吗？
Honestly, It's sad. I mean, I have a feeling of sadness. But I also have a feeling of acceptance. We've been apart for 20 years in the mutual prime of our lives. When I was raising my children and he was a grandparent, we weren't together. And so, I guess, I'm just accepting of where he is.
老实说，很悲伤。我的意思是，我有一种悲伤的感觉。但我也有一种接受的感觉。我们在我们人生的黄金时期分开了20年。当我抚养我的孩子时，他是祖父母，我们没有在一起。所以，我想，我只是接受他现在的处境。
If we had been together for 20 years, and I had seen the decline, and I had been relating to him emotionally and lovingly all that time, I might feel a deeper sadness. But, even though he's my father, the distance that we've been apart all these years has put some kind of a buffer in there. So this is the guy that I know now. We have a much closer relationship in the way we see each other and talk to each other and have continuity.
如果我们在一起生活了20年，我看到了他的衰退，并且一直与他进行情感和爱的交流，我可能会感到更深层的悲伤。但即使他是我的父亲，这些年来我们分开的距离在中间设置了一种缓冲。所以这就是我现在认识的这个家伙。我们在彼此看待、交谈和保持联系的方式上有着更亲密的关系。
I just know, at one point, you said to him he was your hero. Actually, I thought it was so sweet. And I thought it must be hard to see--
我只是知道，在某个时候，你对他说过他是你的英雄。其实，我觉得那太贴心了。我以为看到——
--your hero fall.
——你的英雄陨落一定很难受。
Yeah, right.
是的，没错。
Well, he was my hero, my childhood hero, you know? But that's so far away. I can't relate to the sadness of that. I mean, I love him in that unequivocal way that a child loves a parent. And I feel, when I care for him, a kind of, I guess, a renewal or a rebirth of feeling in this period.
嗯，他是我的英雄，我童年的英雄，你知道吗？但那是太遥远的事情了。我无法将那种悲伤与现在联系起来。我的意思是，我以孩子爱父母的那种唯一方式爱着他。当我照顾他时，我感到一种，我猜，在这个时期感觉的更新或重生。
I know, when I take him after a shower and I rub him down and I actually feel his head in my hand and I feel his flesh in my hands, it's been many years since I had that kind of contact with my father. And it was a little strange at first. I thought, what's it like to rub this other person's body, touch this other person's body? There's a slight deference. And then I realize it's my pop, you know? And he's in need. He can't take care of himself this way.
我知道，当我带他洗完澡帮他擦干时，我真的用手感受他的头，我的手中感受他的肌肤，我有很多年没有和父亲有那种接触了。起初有点奇怪。我想，抚摸这个人的身体，触碰这个人的身体是什么感觉？有一点敬意。然后我意识到这是我的老爸，你知道吗？他需要照顾。他无法以这种方式照顾自己。
Mom? OK, here's Papa, Mom. Hold on. OK. Here comes Dad.
妈妈？好的，这是爸爸，妈妈。等等。好的。爸爸来了。
Joel? Is it my Joel? Don't you know who I am? Who? What do you mean how come I'm on the phone? Don't get mad at me. Don't get mad at me. It's very important because I've been traveling.
乔尔？是我的乔尔吗？你不知道我是谁吗？谁？你什么意思问我怎么在电话上？别对我生气。别对我生气。这很重要，因为我一直在旅行。
I think my father had a classic marriage of his generation. He loved my mother. She was beautiful and hot-tempered, an exciting person to be with. But he wanted something from her that either he didn't know how to get or she couldn't give. And that was a kind of mother love that he, himself, hadn't experienced.
我觉得我父亲拥有一段他那一代人的经典婚姻。他爱我母亲。她美丽且脾气暴躁，是一个令人兴奋的伴侣。但他想从她那里得到一些他要么不知道如何得到要么她给不了的东西。那是一种他自己没有经历过的母爱。
Oh, yes. I'm OK. No, I'm not having a good time. Are you having a good time? You are, really? OK. I want you to be healthy and strong and smile, Sally.
哦，是的。我很好。不，我过得并不开心。你过得开心吗？你真的吗？好的。我希望你健康强壮，微笑，莎莉。
You know, his mother had been bedridden after his birth. And then she died soon after, so he never really knew her. And that's the deepest groove in his memory, which is, I think, unrequited love.
你知道，他母亲在他出生后就卧床不起了。不久后就去世了，所以他从未真正认识她。这是他记忆中最深的沟壑，也就是，我想，未得到的回报的爱。
Don't get down to judge this because, right now, I'm beginning to face one of Joel's tests. And I will be back home, maybe, who knows, a couple of months from now. I don't know, Sally. Would you go with me the next trip? Would you go with me the next trip? OK. All right, babe. Take care, sweetheart. Be careful, will you? Be careful. Bye-bye.
别在这里做评判，因为现在，我开始面对乔尔的考验之一。我会回家的，也许，谁知道呢，几个月后。我不知道，莎莉。下次旅行你会和我一起去吗？下次旅行你会和我一起去吗？好的。好吧，宝贝。保重，亲爱的。小心点，好吗？小心点。再见。
And I think that, from my point of view now, that, if he had really just loved my mother without demanding something from her or needing something from her, which was that childhood need, that she probably would have just loved him back for the kind, warm, funny man that he was. But, because there was something that he was demanding, she couldn't give it to him. A kind of perverse logic of relationship occurred.
我觉得从我现在的观点来看，如果他当初只是爱我母亲，而不向她索取什么，或者不需要她什么，那是一种童年的需求，那么她很可能会因为他是个善良、温暖、风趣的男人而爱他。但因为他索取了一些她给不了的东西，一种关系的变态逻辑出现了。
She's mad. She's mad about something. She's mad about me. I didn't do nothing.
她生气了。她因为某事生气。她因为我生气。我什么都没做。
Why is she mad?
她为什么生气？
She's mad that's all. She sounded very, very bad. She sounded like she didn't care.
她生气了，就这么简单。她听起来非常、非常糟糕。她听起来好像她不在乎。
Well, she probably was caring a lot.
嗯，她可能在乎很多。
Oh, sure.
哦，当然。
Which is why she was mad that you didn't call.
这就是为什么她因为你没打电话而生气。
I waver also, when I think of her being by herself. And I would rather be there than be here.
当我想到她独自一人时，我也很动摇。我宁愿在那里也不愿在这里。
But you're having such a good time here.
但你在这里玩得很开心。
Yeah. I'm, to my limits, I'm having what I like. And I would love to be involved with [INAUDIBLE]. But the idea is that I always have to include Mama.
是的。我，在我的极限内，我做着我喜欢的事情。我很想参与其中[听不清]。但想法是我总是必须带上妈妈。
Throughout the trip he asked for Sally every single day. "Where's Sally?" "Where's Mom," thinking that she should have been in the car next to him.
在整个旅程中，他每天都问莎莉在哪里。“莎莉在哪里？”“妈妈在哪里，”认为她应该在他旁边的车里。
Sally. Did you leave Sally upstairs there?
莎莉。你把莎莉留在楼上了吗？
Yeah, Pop. We said goodbye to Mom.
是的，老爸。我们跟妈妈说再见了。
No kidding? Right? Because I noticed, right here, that there's no Sally. I thought this was Sally all bundled up, and I see it's not bundled up.
别开玩笑了？对吧？因为我注意到，就在这里，没有莎莉。我还以为这是包得严严实实的莎莉，结果发现没包起来。
It's your pillow. That bed pillow's going to have to be your Sally for the next two weeks, though.
那是你的枕头。不过那个床枕头得在接下来的两周里当你的莎莉了。
Yeah, yeah, the pillow. Oh, you guys are starting to pull tricks on me now. I know. I know. I know. Well, is she--was she here?
是的，是的，那个枕头。哦，你们现在开始跟我耍花招了。我知道。我知道。我知道。好吧，她——她在这里吗？
Nope. That's your pillow, Pop.
不。那是你的枕头，老爸。
Jesus Christ, almighty. I know she's not in the trunk. You wouldn't do that to her. I'm not even going to come through this Joel. You know, I'm not the smartest or the cutest in the service. If my mommy don't come up, and then don't come down in five minutes, I want to know where she is. This is my wife.
上帝啊，万能的。我知道她不在后备箱里。你不会那样对她的。我甚至不想说这个，乔尔。你知道，我不是服务中最聪明或最可爱的。如果我的妈咪没上来，五分钟后没下来，我想知道她在哪里。这是我的妻子。
So we'd better check the trunk.
所以我们最好检查一下后备箱。
Yeah, or the bed is in the trunk. I wouldn't be surprised.
是的，或者床在后备箱里。我不会感到惊讶的。
There was a time, when we were driving with her in Florida before we made the film, and she was sitting right next to him. And he leaned over to me and he said, "Where's Mom?" And I said, "Well, who's sitting next to you?" And he looked over at this person sitting next to him and he said, "Where's Sally? That's not Sally."
有一次，在我们拍电影前和她在佛罗里达开车时，她就坐在他旁边。他向我倾过身来说，“妈妈在哪里？”我说，“坐在你旁边的是谁？”他看着坐在他旁边的那个人说，“莎莉在哪里？那不是莎莉。”
When my father was young, he was a wonderful dancer and athlete and a natural comic. And I guess Charlie Chaplin was the rage. And, just as there were Elvis imitators, there were Chaplin imitators. And, my father, he became a Chaplin imitator. And he had that act that, I guess, he took on the road or around the vaudeville circuit in New York.
当我父亲年轻的时候，他是一位出色的舞者、运动员和天生的喜剧演员。我猜当时查理·卓别林风靡一时。就像有猫王模仿者一样，也有卓别林模仿者。我父亲，他成了卓别林模仿者。他有那个表演，我想，他带到纽约的杂耍表演巡回演出中。
I was trying to fit in myself too, all the years, with the joking. I was trying to be a Chaplin. I didn't know if I was doing that right or wrong. But I saw that poor little guy that he'd bend down, pick something up, everybody'd give him a kick in the ass. That was what I used to see. That is what I didn't want to happen to me.
这些年来，我也试图用那些笑话融入其中。我试图成为一个卓别林。我不知道我做得是对还是错。但我看到那个可怜的小家伙弯下腰，捡起什么东西，每个人都会踢他的屁股。这就是我过去看到的。那是我不想发生在我身上的事。
What was it that you liked about Charlie Chaplin, that made you want to do the Charlie Chaplin act?
关于查理·卓别林，是什么让你想做查理·卓别林的表演？
He was a giant in the height of a little midget. He was a little guy righting all the wrongs, helping others. As he'd pass by, we'd pat him on the top of the head. He was remembered out there.
他是一个矮人身高里的巨人。他是一个扶正一切错误、帮助他人的小个子。当他经过时，我们会拍拍他的头顶。人们记得他。
And I just meditate, look at the little party. And the little person had no money or no nothing. And he was going-- on the inside. He'd come out here, like this, like shake his shoulders and then traveled on. And that was what I loved, the goodness, the goodness. And not everybody understood him. But those that understood him, they would put their arm around him, and he would do the same. But it was a beautiful deed for the day.
我只是冥想，看着那个小派对。那个小人物没钱，什么都没有。他正在——在内心深处。他会像这样出来，耸耸肩，然后继续旅行。那就是我所爱的，善良，善良。并不是每个人都理解他。但那些理解他的人，他们会把手搭在他的肩上，他也会这样做。但这对他那一天来说是一种美丽的善举。
Did you feel connected to him in that way?
你觉得你以那种方式和他有联系吗？
Always. Always. Always.
总是。总是。总是。
Aw.
噢。
With Alzeimer's disease, most memory finally dissolves. And, even though he was a man who was easily lovable, I think he forgot that these were his qualities. And that he was, in fact, loved by people faded from his memory. And, at the end of his life, he remembers a few of the more painful things-- that he's a motherless child, that he was not loved the way he wanted to be loved. And it's amazing that, with the murkiness of Alzheimer's clouding everything, that something as primal as being an unloved child stayed with him.
随着阿尔茨海默症的发展，大多数记忆最终都会消散。尽管他是一个很容易被爱的人，但我认为他忘记了这些都是他的品质。他事实上被人们爱过的事实从他的记忆中消失了。而在他生命的最后，他记得一些更痛苦的事情——他是一个没妈的孩子，他没有得到他想要的爱。令人惊讶的是，尽管阿尔茨海默症的阴霾笼罩着一切，但像做一个不可爱的孩子这样原始的东西却留在了他心中。
Well, everybody would show a little bit of something to me that I was accepted. And they would talk to me. And they'd pat me on the top of the head or they'd put their hands around me. I'm home.
嗯，每个人都会对我表现出一丁点我也被接受的感觉。他们会跟我说话。他们会拍拍我的头顶，或者把手放在我身上。我回家了。
I loved everybody. I loved everybody, but nobody saw me. Nobody remembered me. Nobody knew me and nobody saw me, but I was there. And, to this very day, I have the same thing. I have poor Mommy and she doesn't see me. She doesn't see me.
我爱每个人。我爱每个人，但没有人看到我。没有人记得我。没有人认识我，也没有人看到我，但我在这里。直到今天，我也还有同样的事情。我有可怜的妈咪，她看不到我。她看不到我。
Aw, Pop. Well, your boys saw you. We all saw you. I loved when you were the strong man in the neighborhood, but I loved when you were the Chaplin figure and the comic. I loved the way you drove the car. You were such a great driver.
噢，老爸。嗯，你的儿子看见了你。我们都看见了。我喜欢你做街区强人的时候，但我更喜欢你做卓别林人物和喜剧演员的时候。我喜欢你开车的方式。你是一位伟大的司机。
I loved the way you talked to people. You could talk to the big guys or the little guys, and you made them all the same, Pop. I used to think of you as the great equalizer. You could take a guy who was a doctor, or a principal of the school, or a business man, and you can take another guy, who was just an ordinary worker, and you would treat them the same. And you would bring them all to the same level, and that would be the level of laughter.
我喜欢你与人交谈的方式。你能和大人物或小人物交谈，你让他们都一样，老爸。我过去常把你当作伟大的平衡者。你能带一个医生、校长或商人，也能带另一个只是普通工人的人，你会同等地对待他们。你会把他们都带到同一个水平，那就是欢笑的水平。
You saw me. You saw Papa.
你看见了我。你看见了爸爸。
That's right.
那是对的。
Joel Meyerowitz; his father, Hy; his son, Sasha. In the year since they recorded that footage, Hy has died. Joel and Sasha cut their footage into a film. It's called, Pop. It aired on the PBS show, Frontline. This September, Joel is putting out a book, called Aftermath , with his large-format photos from the Ground Zero site in New York City. Coming up, can a dad try too hard? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
乔尔·迈耶罗维茨；他的父亲海伊；他的儿子萨沙。在他们录制那些素材后的几年里，海伊去世了。乔尔和萨沙将他们的素材剪辑成了一部电影。它叫《老爸》。它在PBS的节目《前线》中播出。今年九月，乔尔将出版一本书，名为《余波》，其中收录了他从纽约市归零地拍摄的大画幅照片。接下来，父亲会不会用力过猛？一会儿从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目中揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, for Father's Day, we bring you stories of kids trying to care for and protect their dads and dads trying to protect and care for their kids.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，为了父亲节，我们为您带来关于孩子试图照顾和保护他们的父亲，以及父亲试图保护和照顾他们的孩子的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Age of Enchantment. Lawrence Weschler is an author and journalist. He used to write a lot for The New Yorker magazine. This story is about his attempt to protect his daughter, Sarah, from disappointment and to thrill her. And how, with the best of intentions, all of this went awry and led to an odd breach of trust between father and child. He and Sarah went into a studio in New York City to tell us this story. At the time, Sarah was 11 years old. The story begins simply enough.
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“魔幻时代”。劳伦斯·韦斯勒是一位作家和记者。他过去常为《纽约客》杂志撰稿。这个故事是关于他试图保护他的女儿莎拉免受失望并让她感到兴奋。以及这一切如何在最好的初衷下，却适得其反，导致了父女之间奇怪的信任破坏。他和莎拉走进纽约市的一间录音室来告诉我们这个故事。当时，莎拉11岁。故事开始得很简单。
She would get into very active conversations with the characters in the books while we were reading. So, for example, when we were reading Little House on the Prairie there would be these moments where she would interrupt my reading and say, "Wait a second. I want to talk to the Indian." And we'd have to go look for a picture of the Indian.
我们在读书时，她会与书中的角色进行非常活跃的对话。例如，当我们在读《大草原上的小木屋》时，会出现一些时刻，她会打断我的阅读说：“等一下。我想跟印第安人说话。”我们就得去寻找印第安人的照片。
And she'd say to the Indian, "Now look, Indian, in a few pages you're going to meet Laura, but you've got to understand. I know she's taking your land, but it's not her fault. She's just a kid. Now, let me talk to Laura." And we'd go back and we'd talk to Laura. And in these things I would take on the role of the Indian, and I'd say things like, "Who's that talking," and so forth. And we would have these incredibly elaborate conversations. Do you remember that, Sarah?
她会对印第安人说，“现在听着，印第安人，再过几页你就会遇见劳拉，但你得明白。我知道她在抢占你的土地，但这不是她的错。她只是个孩子。现在，让我跟劳拉说话。”然后我们回去和劳拉说话。在这些事情中，我会扮演印第安人的角色，我会说像“是谁在说话”之类的话。我们会进行极其复杂的对话。你记得吗，莎拉？
Yes.
是的。
Anyway, this sort of thing would go on all the time. And, at a later point, we began reading The Borrowers series, the series of wonderful books by Mary Noble.
总之，这种事情总是发生。后来，我们开始读《借东西的人》系列，玛丽·诺布尔写的精彩丛书。
Norton.
诺顿。
Mary-- excuse me.
玛丽——抱歉。
Norton.
诺顿。
By Mary Norton, that's right. And, well, should Sarah describe what the book is about, maybe?
玛丽·诺顿，对，没错。嗯，莎拉或许应该描述一下这本书是关于什么的？
Sure. Sarah, explain what the borrowers are like.
当然。莎拉，解释一下借东西的人是什么样的。
Well, The Borrowers , it's about these little people who are, I think, like four inches tall. And they live under the floorboards in the house. And what they do is they take things from people, little things, that they can use around their house.
嗯，《借东西的人》，它是关于这些小人的，我想，大约四英寸高。他们住在房子里的地板下面。他们做的是从人类那里拿走东西，小东西，他们可以在家里用的小东西。
So what kinds of things do they take?
那么他们拿什么样的东西呢？
Well, they take pocket watches, and stamps, or pictures on the wall.
嗯，他们拿怀表、邮票或墙上的画。
And part of the point about borrowers is that they're not allowed-- are they allowed to talk to people?
关于借东西的人，重点之一是他们不被允许——他们被允许和人类说话吗？
No.
不。
Do you want to talk about that a little bit?
你想谈谈这个吗？
Well, because they think that people can really hurt them because, according to the book, it's happened before.
嗯，因为他们认为人类真的会伤害他们，因为根据书中所说，以前发生过这种事。
Right.
没错。
So, anyway, we were reading this book. And one day I came home and Sarah was incredibly excited. Her face was just glowing. She said, "Daddy! You won't believe it! We have borrowers here in our own house!"
总之，我们当时在读这本书。有一天我回家，莎拉兴奋极了。她的脸容光焕发。她说：“爸爸！你不会相信的！我们家里有借东西的人！”
And my memory is that-- maybe you remember this differently, Sarah, but-- my memory was that she went to a particular place in the basement. And she pointed at this little hole in the wall in the basement near the floor. And she said, "I was coming down the stairs. And there was one of them standing right there, a little girl. And she was wearing a pink taffeta skirt." That's what you said. "And I froze. And she froze. And we looked at each other. And I knew I wasn't supposed to talk to her, that she shouldn't talk to me, but we just looked at each other. And, after about 30 seconds, she kind of waved her hand, just slightly, and she ran away. And it was right there." And Sarah took me to the place where it was.
我的记忆是——也许你的记忆不同，莎拉——我的记忆是她去了地下室的一个特定地方。她指着地下室地板附近墙上的那个小洞。她说：“我正从楼梯上下来。其中一个就站在那里，一个小女孩。她穿着粉红色的塔夫绸裙子。”那是你说的。“我僵住了。她也僵住了。我们互相对视。我知道我不应该跟她说话，她也不应该跟我说话，但我们只是看着对方。大约30秒后，她挥了挥手，只是稍微挥了一下，然后跑掉了。就在那里。”莎拉带我去了那个地方。
And, Sarah, let me just ask you. What do you remember of this?
莎拉，让我问你一下。你对此有什么记忆？
Well, I remember having seen-- well, you see, it's so strange to say this because I feel like I'm betraying the borrowers, but I still believe in them. And, if I ever actually got to meet one, I'd never tell anyone. And I do remember having seen something. And it wasn't really for 30 seconds. It was for, maybe, 10 seconds, and then it ran away.
嗯，我记得确实看到过——嗯，你看，说这些太奇怪了，因为我觉得我在背叛借东西的人，但我仍然相信他们。如果我真的有机会遇到一个，我也永远不会告诉任何人。我确实记得看到过什么。其实并不是30秒。也许只有10秒，然后它就跑掉了。
And, even now when you think about it, you can picture? You can picture seeing it?
即使现在当你想到它时，你还能想象吗？你还能想象看到它吗？
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And I didn't imagine it. It was definitely there.
是的。是的。是的。我没有想象它。它绝对在那里。
And it was a little girl?
而且是一个小女孩？
Yeah, I think.
是的，我想是。
OK.
好的。
And then, over the next few days, Sarah began leaving things for this borrower. And the first thing in the morning she would race downstairs to see whether the things had been picked up.
然后，在接下来的几天里，莎拉开始为这个借东西的人留下东西。每天早上第一件事，她就会冲下楼去看看东西有没有被拿走。
Do you remember what kind of things you left?
你记得你留下了什么样的东西吗？
Sometimes I'd leave toothpicks or pieces of food.
有时候我会留下牙签或食物碎片。
What do they use toothpicks for?
他们用牙签做什么？
Oh, just to dig with, you know?
哦，只是用来挖东西，你知道吗？
Kind of an all-purpose tool?
算是一种多用途工具？
Yeah.
是的。
走路棍。
Walking stick.
是的。
Yeah.
像那样的东西。
Things like that.
总之，她会把这些东西留在那。她会非常失望，失望到近乎绝望，因为东西没被拿走。她会跟我进行长谈。她说：“为什么他们不拿走？他们不知道我在给他们吗？”我会试着解释，也许，他们很害怕、紧张，或者别的什么，借东西的人就是那样。
Anyway, so she would leave these things there. And she would be so disappointed, and disappointment verging on desolation, that they weren't picked up. And she'd have long conversations with me. She said, "Why aren't they picking them up? Don't they know that I'm giving it to them?" And I would try to explain that, maybe, they were scared, or nervous, or something, that's how borrowers are.
但她太难过了。这种情况持续了下去。我以为这会结束，但在某个时候，这种情况持续了一周。我不知道我为什么要这么做，因为它引发了一连串后果。但有一天晚上，我捡起那些东西放进了口袋。第二天早上，她跑上楼说：“爸爸！你不会相信的！真的有借东西的人！他们拿走了东西！他们拿走了东西！”她欣喜若狂。我以为那是结束了，但并没有。
But she was so sad. And this went on. I figured this would end but, at some point, this went on for a week. And I don't know why I did it because it began a cascade of consequences. But one night I picked up the stuff and put it in my pocket. And, the next morning, she came bounding up the stairs saying, "Daddy! You won't believe it! There are borrowers just like I said! They took the stuff! They took the stuff!" And she was transported with delight. And I figured that would be the end of it, but it wasn't.
那么，接下来发生了什么，莎拉？
Well, what happened next, Sarah?
我开始给他们写信。我开始写信。
I started writing to them. I started writing letters.
好的。为什么我不请你拿出其中一封信，让我们听听你第一封信写了什么？
OK. Why don't I ask you to pull out one of those letters, and let's hear what you wrote for the first one.
好吧，第一封。好的。
All right, the first one. OK.
你当时六岁，对吧？
Now, you were six at the time, right?
七岁。
Seven.
亲爱的借东西的人，我看见过你们，但我想要认识你们。如果我认识了，我不会在没有你们许可的情况下告诉任何人。同意，还是不同意？然后这是借东西的人解释——
Dear Borrowers, I have seen you, but I want to meet you. If I do, I will not tell anyone without your permission. Agreed, or not agreed? And then this is the borrower explaining--
等一下。所以发生的事情是，那张贴在小黄色便利贴上的纸条在那洞口放了好几天。接下来的好几个早晨，莎拉都为它没有得到回应而彻底崩溃。我过了好几天不知道该怎么办，因为她对此越来越难过，越来越担心。所以我想到，捡起那张纸写个小小的回信大概不会有什么坏处，我确实这么做了。
Just one second. So what happened is that, that note on a little yellow Post-it, lay by the hole for several days. And for several mornings Sarah would be completely devastated that it had not been answered. So I went through several days of not quite knowing what to do because she was getting more and more sad about this and more concerned. And so then I figured, well, it won't do any harm to pick up the piece of paper and write a little, tiny message back, which I did.
你那也有吗？
Do you have that there as well?
是的，就在同一张纸上。
Yeah, it's on the same piece of paper.
好的。所以——
OK. So--
亲爱的莎拉，天哪，这太奇怪了。你是谁？你是怎么知道借东西的人的？我以为从来没有人类知道我们。我爸爸说遇到人类对借东西的人来说太危险了。他甚至说我不准写信给你。但也许，至少，我可以写。你会回信吗？我希望如此。我会对我爸爸保密的。签名，安娜贝尔·李。注：我11岁。你呢？
Dear Sarah, gosh, this is strange. Who are you? How do you know about borrowers? I thought no human beings ever knew about us. My dad says it's too dangerous for borrowers to meet a human being. And he even says I mustn't write to you. But maybe, at least, I can write. Will you write back? I hope so. I'll keep it a secret from my dad. Signed, Annabel Lee. PS, I am 11. How about you?
所以你收到了这个。你记得收到这封信吗？
And so you got this. Do you remember getting this letter?
嗯哼。
Mm-hm.
你记得那个早晨吗，你上楼时说了什么？
Do you remember that morning, what you said when you came up the stairs?
不。
No.
她说了什么？你记得吗？
What did she say? Do you remember?
哦，她只是说，“他们是！我告诉你了！我告诉你了！她回信了！她回信了！她想让我回信！”她高兴极了。她立刻回了信。
Oh, she was just, "They are! I told you! I told you! And she answered! She answered! And she wants me to write back!" And she was over the moon. And she wrote back, immediately.
是的。
Yeah.
那么，伦，你把你的借东西的人构想为书中借东西的人的后代吗？
So, Ren, did you conceive of your borrowers as being descendants of the borrowers in the book?
嗯，不清楚。我的意思是，这是一种可能性。这取决于莎拉不断挖掘以找出更多信息。因此，很大一部分通信是莎拉在做家庭家谱工作并问各种各样的问题。
Well, it was unclear. I mean, it was a possibility. And it was up to Sarah to keep dredging and find out more. And so a large part of the correspondences is Sarah doing genealogical work on the family and asking all kinds of questions.
是的，我会问，“你祖母叫什么名字？”结果发现她的祖母是阿里埃蒂，也就是书中的主角。
Yeah, I would ask, "What was your grandmother's name?" And it turned out that her grandmother was Arrietty, which is the main character.
书中的主角？
The main character in the book?
是的。她说她叫她爸爸豌豆，就像豌豆荚一样，因为在书中，爸爸叫波德。
Yeah. And she says that she calls her dad Pea, as in a pea pod, because, in the book, the dad is Pod.
哦。
Oh.
她叫她妈妈霍米，因为在书中，母亲叫霍米莉。
And then she calls her mom Homie because, in the book, the mother is Homily.
信件来回了多久？一共有多少封信？
How long did the letters go back and forth? How many letters were there?
我想有超过17封，因为我没数完，但我数到了17封。
I think there were over 17 because I didn't finish counting, but I counted up to 17.
伦，在这段时间里，你是否担心这一切会走向何方，担心在某个时候你会露馅？
And, Ren, during this time, were you frightened about where this was all going to lead, that at some point you would get found out?
嗯，这变得很奇怪，实际上，有点让人神经紧张。我会做一些事情。我一直以为莎拉会长大而不再相信这些，或者莎拉会联想到这就像我们过去我读印第安人或劳拉故事时所做的那样。我一直以为她会喜欢那样，但她越来越投入其中。它变得越来越复杂。而且投入越深，我越能看出莎拉在其中投入了多少。
Well, it was getting strange and, actually, kind of nerve-wracking. And I would do things. I kept on figuring that Sarah was going to grow out of this or that Sarah would make the association that this was kind of like what we used to do when I would read about the Indian or about Laura. I kept on thinking that she would just enjoy that, but she was getting more and more into it. And it was becoming more and more involved. And the more involved, the more I could see how invested Sarah was in it.
我的意思是，在那段时间里，这确实是她生活中最主要的事情。当她开始告诉朋友这件事时，故事必须变得越来越复杂，以包含所有渗入细节的零碎部分。我不太知道它会去向何方。我会做一些事情。我会把借东西的人送去度假。
I mean, it really was the main thing going on in her life during that season. And, as she began telling friends about it and so forth, the stories had to get more and more elaborate to include all the stray bits of details that were seeping into things. And I didn't quite know where it was going to go. I would do things. I would send the borrowers on vacations.
你把他们送去度假？
You would send them on vacations?
我只会让他们突然消失一会儿。他们会消失一段时间。我希望到结束的时候，莎拉已经忘了。如果我说他们会离开三周，三周后在那一天，莎拉会给他们留一张纸条。
I'd just have them suddenly disappear for a while. And they'd be gone for a while. And I would hope that, by the time it was over, Sarah would have forgotten. If I had said they'd be gone three weeks, there weeks later on that day there'd be a note for them from Sarah.
莎拉，你当时怀疑了吗？
And, Sarah, did you suspect at that point?
没有。没有。就在我怀疑的那一刻，我几乎确定那一直是他。我只是跑上去问他是不是他。
No. No. The second I suspected it, I was almost sure that it had been him. And I just went up and asked him if it was him.
为什么你会开始怀疑？你记得发生了什么让你怀疑吗？
Why is it that you started to suspect? Do you remember what happened that made you suspect?
我想是因为事实上——其实不是他的笔迹。而是我告诉爸爸，例如，我在地下室，我把手指伸进这个洞里，我感觉到了一些柔软或什么的。那可能只是卡在那里的一块旧布。但我感觉到了，我告诉了爸爸。它从我手指滑走了。我告诉了爸爸这件事。
I think it was sort of the fact-- not his handwriting, actually. It was that I would tell my dad, for instance, that I was in the basement and I stuck my finger into this hole, and I felt something sort of silky or something. It was probably just something, an old piece of cloth that was stuck there. But I felt it, and I told my dad. And it sort of slipped away from my finger. And told my dad about it.
然后，在下一封信里，安娜贝尔·李就会说，“哦，是你触碰我时我穿着丝绸连衣裙吗？”所以我开始想，我会告诉爸爸一些事情，有时，我会夸大一点。当我年轻的时候，我夸大了一些事情。我让事情比它们本来可能的样子更令人兴奋了一点。
And then, in the next letter, Annabel Lee'd be saying, "Oh, was that you who touched me when I was wearing my silk dress? And so I started to think I tell my dad things that, sometimes, I'd exaggerate a little bit. When I was younger, I exaggerated some things. I made things a little bit more exciting than they might have really been.
然后我读了那封信，里面有夸大的部分。所以我开始想，那并没有真正发生。我只是把它加到我的故事里了。所以我——
And then I read the letter, and it had that exaggerated part in it. And so I started to go, that didn't really happen. I was just adding that to my story. And so I got--
那让你产生了怀疑？
That made you suspicious?
是的。我问了爸爸，然后——
Yeah. And I asked my dad, and--
所以发生的事情是我们搬到了新房子。到那时我们已经住了几个月了。我在地下室搬动一些盒子。莎拉下来了。
So what happened there was we had moved to the new house. We had been there for a couple of months at that point. And I was down in the basement moving some boxes around. And Sarah came down there.
多少岁？
And, how old?
她现在八岁。是的。
She's now eight. Yeah.
好的。在这个故事里，是的。
OK. In this story, yeah.
在故事的这一点上，是的。她开始了。她的嘴唇在颤抖。她的下唇在颤抖。她很坚定地看着我，像她非常有能力做到的那样。她说：“爸爸，我现在要问你一个问题，你必须说实话，因为爸爸对女儿撒谎是一种罪过。”我的心沉了下去。
At this point in the story, yeah. And she began. Her lips were trembling. Her lower lip was trembling. And she looked at me very firmly as she is quite capable of doing. And she said, "Daddy, I'm going to ask you a question now, and you have to tell the truth because it's a sin for daddies to lie to their daughters." And my heart just sank.
她说，“爸爸，是你一直在写安娜贝尔·李的字条吗？”我看着她。她看着我。有五六秒钟的沉默。然后我说，“你知道，这有点复杂。我们能谈谈——”她说，“爸爸，这不复杂。很简单。是你吗？”我说，“好吧，我们能晚点谈吗？”她说，“不。告诉我。到底是不是你？”我深吸了一口气说，“是的，是我。”然后她爆发了——
And she said, "Daddy, are you the one who's been writing Annabel Lee's notes?" And I looked at her. And she looked at me. And there was silence for five or six seconds. And then I said, "You know, it's kind of complicated. Can we talk--" and she said, "Daddy, it's not complicated. It's simple. Are you the one?" And I said, "Well, can we talk about it later?" She said, "No. Just tell me. Are you the one or not?" And I took a big breath and I said, "Yes, it is me." And she broke into--
我在哭。
I was crying.
噢，天哪。她在啜泣。
Oh, god. She was sobbing.
我太难过了。
I was so sad.
她开始啜泣。这绝对是我为人父母到那时为止发生的最痛苦的事情。我的意思是，我完全搞砸了。我只感到彻底的灾难。我在哭。她在哭。你知道，我们俩都有点互相紧抓着，抱着对方。我们真的陷在那个陷阱里了。我们在那个洞里。我们陷入了大麻烦。
She started sobbing. It was, easily, the most wrenching thing that had happened in my parenthood up to that point. I mean, I had totally blown it. I just felt total disaster. And I was crying. And she was crying. And, you know, we were both kind of clutching each other and holding each other. And we were really in a trap there. We were down the hole at that point. We were in big trouble.
突然，莎拉脸上出现了一种平静。就像早晨升起的太阳。她的前额不再紧锁。它变得平滑了。她只是看着我说，“爸爸，你没意识到吗？你毁了一切，因为借东西的人是真的。而且你在他们能够拿到信之前就把信拿走了。”她解决了所有的问题，因为，除其他事项外，那正是她能够告诉朋友的事情。她们都可以对她有一个多么疯狂的父亲而咯咯大笑。这太惊人了。她找到了一种让我们摆脱这场我本应为我们打造的灾难的方法。
And, suddenly, this kind of calm came over Sarah's face. It was kind of like the sun rising in the morning. And her forehead stopped being furrowed. It became smooth. And she just looked at me, and she said, "Daddy, don't you realize? You've ruined everything because there are borrowers. And you were taking the letters before they were able to get them." And she had solved everything there because, among other things, that  was what she was going to be able to tell her friends. And they could all chortle about what kind of a crazy father she had. And it was amazing. She found a way of getting us out of this disaster that, I suppose, I had fashioned for us.
因为我记得你说过你应该把它留在那里。也许他们真的会回信。你不该那样做，因为也许他们最后真的会在某个时候给我回信。
Because I remember saying that you should have left it there. Maybe they would have really written back. You shouldn't have done it because maybe they would have actually written back to me, finally, at some point.
正如我之前所说的，我仍然相信他们。我知道这对一些可能会听这个的孩子来说可能听起来很幼稚，但我仍然相信他们。当我告诉梅根，我的朋友，当我告诉梅根那是我爸爸时，她不再相信他们了。从那时起，只要我提到它，她就会嘲笑我，告诉我，“哦，莎拉，别这么幼稚。”因为她比我大一岁，所以当时，她仍然认为自己比我优秀，尽管我们是最好的朋友。她说，“哦，莎拉，别这么幼稚。这不是真的。这不是真的。你可以停止想象它了。别再跟我说了，因为这不是真的。”
Like I said earlier, I still believe in them. And I know that may sound really baby-ish to some kids who might listen to this, but I still believe in them. And when I told Megan, my friend, when I told Megan that it had been my dad, she stopped believing in them. And she'd just, whenever I'd talk about it from then on, she'd laugh at me and tell me, "Oh, Sarah, stop being a baby." Because she's a year older than me, so she, at that time, she still considered herself really superior to me even though we were best friends. And she said, "Oh, Sarah, stop being a baby. It's not true. It's just not true." And I said, "But I've seen them." And she said, "No, you haven't. You just imagined it. And it's not true. And you can just stop imagining it. And stop telling me about it because it's not true."
当你现在看着那些信时，你感觉如何？
How do you feel about it now when you look at those letters?
我不知道。有时候，当我读它们时，我仍然会想，“我不知道为什么这发生在她身上？我不知道为什么那个发生在她身上？我不知道她为什么会那样说？”即使我知道是我爸爸写的，我有时仍然认为在外面某个地方有一个安娜贝尔·李。
I don't know. Sometimes, when I read them, I still can think, "I wonder why this happened to her? I wonder why that happened to her? I wonder why she would say that?" Even though I'd know that it was my dad writing to me, I still, sometimes, think of there being an Annabel Lee somewhere out there.
昨晚我们拿出盒子看那些信的时候，看那些信给你带来了快乐吗？
When we pulled out the box last night, of letters, did it bring you pleasure to look at those letters?
嗯，其实，我经常看它。
Well, actually, I look at it a lot.
你经常看？
You do?
是的。
Yeah.
你经常看它？
You look at it a lot?
是的。
Yeah.
你看着它时想什么？
And what do you think when you look at it?
嗯，现在回想起来，他那样做还是挺好的。因为我记得，当它发生时，在我意识到是他之后，我问过他，“嗯，我们还能互相写信吗？”但我们之后其实再也没有互相写过信。
Well, now, looking back, it was sort of nice of him to do that. Because I remember, when it was happening and after I had figured out that it was him, I had asked him, "Well, can we still write to each other?" And we never really, actually, wrote to each other after that.
但我只是想，过了一段时间，这是一件好事。而且，即使，也许没有借东西的人给我写信，也许，让我爸爸编造这一整家人，也许，一样特别。或者也许几乎和真的给借东西的人写信一样特别。
But I just thought, after a while, that it was a nice thing. And that, even though, maybe there was no borrower writing to me, there was, maybe, having my dad make up this whole family was, maybe, just as special. Or maybe almost as special as having actually been writing to a borrower.
莎拉，我可以问你，你认为这个故事的教训是什么吗？也就是说，如果父母听你讲这个故事，你和你爸爸在广播里讲这个故事，如果另一个父母陷入这种境地，你给他们的建议是什么？他们应该随波逐流吗？他们应该写信，他们应该捡起东西吗？
Sarah, can I ask you, what do you think the lesson of this story is? That is, if parents hear you tell this story, you and your dad tell this story on the radio, and, if another parent gets into this kind of situation, what's your advice for them? Should they go along with it? Should they write letters, and should they pick up stuff?
我不知道，因为那种体验对我来说真的很有趣。但是，当我发现是我爸爸写的，真的很让人心烦。所以我只是——我不知道。我想我不会。如果我是父母，我有那种情况，我不会捡起来。
I don't know, because it was really fun for me to have this kind of experience. But, when I found out that it was my dad writing, it was really upsetting. And so I just-- I don't know. I think that I wouldn't. If I were a parent and I had that kind of thing, I would not pick it up.
你不会？
You would not?
不。我会鼓励我的孩子继续给借东西的人写信，并试着让他们回信，但我不会捡起来。
No. I would keep encouraging my kid and my child to keep on writing to the borrowers and trying to get them to write back, but I wouldn't pick it up.
如果他们每天早上都那么难过地来到你面前，像你当时难过地来到我面前一样，只是恳求，“我希望。我希望。我希望他们会来？”你能想象自己会捡起来吗？
What if they keep coming to you so sad every morning, the way you were sad coming to me, and just pleading, "I wish. I wish. I wish they would come?" Can you imagine ever picking it up?
不能。
No.
真的吗？
Really?
我觉得这样诱导别人是不公平的。
I don't think it's fair to lead someone on like that.
伦，就你而言，这个故事的教训是什么？如果你能重来，如果你再次陷入这种情况，或者如果你能带着后见之明回去，你会怎么做？你会留下那些信吗？
Ren, as far as you're concerned, what's the lesson of this story? If you had this to do again, if you would get into this situation again or if you could go back with the benefit of hindsight, what would you do? Would you have left the letters?
我的意思是，我想说，如果能重活一次，我不会这样做。但我不敢肯定，因为它开始得太自然了。最终，顺便说一句，我必须说的是，我生命中某个阶段最感人、最亲密、最不可思议的时刻，就是我们在地下室互相紧抱着，我们两个都在哭，但莎拉没有跑开，莎拉救了我们。那以一种非常美妙的方式巩固了我们的关系。
I mean, I'd like to say that, had I to live it over again, I wouldn't do it this way. But I'm not sure because it started so naturally. And, in the end, by the way, what I'd have to say is probably the most poignant, closest, amazing moment I've had, you know, the moment I'll remember of a particular phase of my life, is the holding onto each other in the basement, both of us crying, but Sarah not running away and Sarah saving us. And that kind of cemented our relationship in a really wonderful way.
并不是对每个人来说结果都会是那样。
It might not end that way for everybody.
是的，并不是对每个人来说结果都会是那样。那是真的。我继续琢磨它。它对我来说还没解决，就像我的回答所表明的那样，我想。
Yeah, it might not end that way for everybody. That's true. I continue to puzzle about it. And it is unresolved for me, as my answer is indicating, I suppose.
这很有趣，我觉得你对这个故事教训的看法是莎拉救了你们两个。作为父母，你让自己陷入了一个你真的不知道该怎么办的时刻，最后是她说的话让一切都变好了。
It's interesting, to me that the way that you view the lesson of this story is that Sarah saved the two of you. That, as a parent, you got yourself into a moment where you literally didn't know what to do, and that she finally said the thing that made everything OK.
我绝对有这种感觉。你认为它影响了我们的关系吗？你不像以前那样信任我了吗？
I absolutely feel that. Has it affected our relationship, do you think? Do you not trust me in the way you used to trust me?
不。不。不，我仍然信任你。
No. No. No, I still trust you.
莎拉，你认为这是你与父亲最亲密的时刻之一吗？
Sarah, do you view this as one of the moments when you were closest to your dad?
嗯，我和爸爸很亲密，所以我不知道。这就像，是的，我想是吧。但这不像是我通常那样的亲密，因为我可能一直都和爸爸很亲密。但，是的，这是我最亲密的时刻之一，我想。是的。
Well, I'm very close my dad, so I don't know. It's like, yeah, I guess so. But it's not like much closer than I am usually because I'm probably close to my dad all the time. But, yeah, it is one of the times that I was closest, I guess. Yeah.
所以，我的心都在嗓子眼了。
So, my heart is in my throat.
劳伦斯·韦斯勒，他现在是芝加哥人文艺术节的艺术总监。他也是许多书的作者，包括他最新的书，《一切上升的东西》，《融合之书》。
Lawrence Weschler, he's now the artistic director of the Chicago Humanities Festival. And he's the author of many books, including his latest, Everything That Rises , A Book of Convergences.
莎拉现在19岁。过去一年，她在坦桑尼亚的一个偏远村庄教幼儿园。秋天她就要上大学了。当我们在八年前录制这次采访时，她说即使在我们录制采访的时候她仍然相信借东西的人。事实上，她说她会听这个故事，但不是在屋里。她要在车里听。
Sarah is now 19. This past year, she's been teaching kindergarten in a remote village in Tanzania. She goes off to college in the fall. Back when we recorded this interview, eight years ago, she said that even at the time that we were recording the interview she still believed in the borrowers. In fact, she said she was going to listen to the story, but not in the house. She was going to listen in the car.
我不想我们在家里听它，因为如果屋子里还有借东西的人，我不想让他们听到这个，然后认为他们不能信任我。因为，现在，我正在讲他们的整个故事，所以我感觉我好像是在背叛他们。我只是想确保他们知道这一点，你知道吗？如果我真的遇见一个，我不会告诉任何人。我永远不会告诉世界上任何一个人。
I don't want us to listen to it at the house because, if there are still borrowers in our house, I don't want them to hear that and think that they can't trust me. Because, right now, I'm telling their whole story, so I feel like I'm sort of betraying them. And I just wanted to make sure that they knew that, you know? If I actually did meet one, I wouldn't tell anyone. I would never tell a single person in the world.
我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和豪尔赫·贾斯特。本节目的特约编辑有保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃维尔。托德·巴克曼、西尔维娅·莱姆斯、萨蒂瓦·詹纳里和塞斯·林德提供了制作协助。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alex Blumberg, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and Jorge Just. Contributing editors for this show Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere, Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Sylvia Lemus, Sativa January, and Seth Lind.
[鸣谢]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们所有24小时的节目和档案。或者，你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to all of our programs and our archives for absolutely free, 24 hours a day. Or, you know, you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
[资金赞助鸣谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他每次有人选择不向这个电台捐款时都会宣布——
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia who declares every time someone chooses not to pledge to this radio station--
我觉得我失去了我的精神支柱。
I feel like I've lost my spirit.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。给我远在马里兰州巴尔的摩的爸爸，巴里·格拉斯，父亲节快乐，爸爸。很快在纽约市见，好吗？给剩下的所有人，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. To my dad, Barry Glass, off in Baltimore, Maryland, happy Father's Day, Dad. And see you soon in New York City, OK? To all the rest of you, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
PRI。国际公共广播电台。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。